I want you to consider this bet here's
$10 this could be yours if I flip this
print in the air you guys call it in the
air if you're right I'll give you the
$10 if you're wrong you give me $10
that's not a good bet for me I guess in
in principle I don't agree with the the
idea of betting okay okay but what if we
just use this as like an allegory for
life you know it's not really about
money and and betting on a coin it's
more about our approach to risk okay and
my approach to risk is so obviously a
lot less than here's you wouldn't do
this bet huh
my gut says don't bet why is that
because at the moment I have ten dollars
and later I might not so people are
passing up the opportunity to win ten
dollars of my money but it kind of makes
sense because they have to risk ten
dollars of their money and it's a 50-50
chance
so really the bet has zero value what if
I sweeten the deal what if I put up
twelve dollars to your tent
you only stand to lose ten you stand to
gain twelve how's that sound
I wouldn't I still wouldn't bet I feel
like I'm better off just leaving it as
it is I love you fifteen dollars
you only have to put up ten I'm putting
up fifteen I'm offering you $5 why not
what about twenty as as high as I'm
going today $20 that is the top it's two
to one I just don't like taking that
much risk you don't like risking ten
bucks sure all right ten dollars I am
but why don't you value my twenty
dollars but you've got a 50% chance of
right here if you take if you accept the
bet I don't know I can't tell you it's
not like a I don't know what the logical
reason is for
want that I don't know I can't Lee I
just feel it's not right now this
doesn't make sense
I've offered people up to $20 and
they're still refusing to take the bet
the bet is objectively in their favor
I'm in a 50 percent chance of winning 20
plus a 50% chance of losing 10 still
gives the bet an overall value of $5 why
is it that you won't you won't go for
this bet I don't know because I don't
want to lose $10 just because of Daddy's
Betty's a week I know but you could win
$20 think about the game I don't know
I'm thinking more about what I lose than
what I win I think I think that's
exactly the point because we feel losses
more than we feel gains there's an
asymmetry in the way people perceive
gains and losses losses are felt much
more intensely in fact psychologically
most people weight a loss around twice
as heavily as a gain but this varies
from person to person what if I go to
$30 I said even if you had 50 I would
still feel the same way
$50 to $10 that would be a reasonable
that's when you would say yes possibly
is you're gonna have to give me like a
hundred this is known as loss aversion
to avoid risking a loss people will pass
up even very favorable bets but is there
a way to overcome our over sensitivity
to losses
let me ask you this what if I offered to
do this ten times in a row same deal
$20 for your 10 flip in this coin but
then I'd be losing $10 each time one you
might be you'd be risking $10 each time
but you know this is 5050 and you know
that I'm giving you ten chances
is that a better deal to do it
repeatedly I didn't think so
what about hundred times it doesn't get
better no if we played enough and I had
enough
you know the stake of $10 then
eventually yes I would make more money
yes what is repeating the same bet
changes I don't think there's a rational
thought behind it it's just a feeling
that one gets when presented with the
opportunity I don't know I think there
is a rational reason behind it is it
yeah because the coin is gonna be 50/50
you don't know one toss you're only
gonna get one outcome but in a hundred
tosses you know that it's gonna be
somewhere between like 45 and 55 times
it's gonna go your way 45 to 50 times 55
times it's gonna go my way right the
point is every time it goes your way you
win twice as much as you lose when it
goes my way so point is doing it a
hundred times you're basically
guaranteed to win money no no it's not
more chances of winning it is you are
guaranteed to win money in fact the
expected value of a hundred of these
bets is a win of $500 and there's only a
1 in 2,300 chance of losing any money at
all so even if you weight losses twice
as much as gains a hundred bets is
indisputably favorable so here's the
thing how do you accept a hundred of
these bets
if you won't first accept one of those
bets this experiment is not about
gambling it's not to encourage you to go
to the casino where the odds are
definitely stacked against you instead
it is a metaphor for all the little
risks and opportunities that come our
way in our lives I mean if you view each
one as an independent event you will
often say no to even very good bets
because you're afraid of the loss so if
instead you can see each little bet as
one of a series of bets then you realize
that if you take that bet every time you
may win and you may lose but overall on
the aggregate you will come out ahead
[Music]
it's heads it is he's just won himself
12 bucks whoo-hoo tails the 10 bucks is
yours sir ladies sir
heads thank you very much 120 bucks see
it pays to take the risk
yes this is unbelievable my stroke of
luck today has been terrible
everyone's won office anymore I'm
finding myself
okay that's honestly my money really
yeah this video is in fact a bit of a
risk for me
because I'm giving out all this money
and it's only gonna make money on
YouTube if like half a million people
see it so if you like this video then
you should share it with your friends so
that this actually turns out to be a
positive bet for me okay I'll do that
yeah share it share with your friends
it's veritasium it's the name of the
website there it's veritasium so would
you take this one off bet let me know in
the comments below and tell me how much
money I would have to put up in order
for you to risk your $10 now this video
was inspired by the book Thinking Fast
and Slow by Daniel Kahneman which I've
recommended before because it's awesome
and it also inspired me to make these
cool videos so check them out if you
haven't already
but since I've recommended this book
before I'm gonna recommend something
different today my friend Phil plate's
book bad astronomy which is all about
misconceptions and misuses of astronomy
from astrology through to the moon
landing hoaxes it is an awesome book so
you should definitely check it out and
in fact you can download it for free by
going to audible.com/veritasium or you
can pick any other book of your choosing
for a one-month free trial audible is a
great audiobook website with over
150,000 titles in all areas of
literature including fiction nonfiction
and periodicals so I really want to
thank audible for supporting me and I
want to thank you for watching